normally you make crowd of people you
think one of them's gonna be a minute
you start going what about you I mean
they think I'm all right but they've
already been like he has said some
things gonna night no they're not they
honestly have where I'm from it's very
bad Irish she's intelligent she's funny
she's crazy
or much the girl version of me really
what you think my friends gonna be like
lesbians that's my birthday
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah yeah what would you fix of your
chosen in terms of thing um I'm as like
a strip club if it was you actually you
know what that would have been funny
there my dear old lesbians I think you
don't like appreciated that or not I
don't know it's not necessary we've got
nice I've got like why do I think you
are if you are if what you're saying by
the minute you start going
what about what do they think I mean
they think I'm alright but they've
already been like he has said some
things that are like no they're not they
don't want to see her where I'm from
it's very banished but you just gotta
stop feeling like autumn might yeah yeah
a13 nice to meet you oh it's at night
very nice to meet ya I used to take my
sister and you grab an ethics I'll go up
in London
Davies James they all like your voice I
think
with your friend over there on a big
wall with a husky voice my god it's
quite good that we all come together and
met different types of people I'm a
plasterer by trade so when I work I
don't really get to meet different lot
of people how I've met today I think
it's going to be a big thick skins and
you can't expect everybody to call you
by the right name
I went hello girls I always call you
girls personally I work on people's
houses and stuff for that
oh I genuinely do go up and I'm hello
love how are you and that is how I would
approach they can acquire like
challenging sand I explain to people
like a person you are and why you are
the way you are what would be the right
thing to say so your vegetating us a
little bit yeah well I mean I guess like
it's normally good just not to guess
where people start off with hello yeah
[Laughter]
talkative summer Lux Chloe who's my
lovely lovely gay old lady you know they
might look at a certain words from
someone like myself not rude but it
makes them feel right it is the biggest
guy in the village
[Applause]
meeting and hearing you talk about
transfer in particular people that
gender-fluid
I've never understood gender policy
until tonight generally it's a spectrum
there's not there's male and female at
either end and then people can be
anywhere alone so I knew that I'm I'm
quite often one I mean not stereotype
but the people like him you tend to shut
down the conversation on both sides
usually from them they would expect I'm
gonna come on to them although I'm some
kind of weird freak and for me I'm like
you're probably gonna beat me up no not
so not in any way to check I'm not
racist or homophobic so off I mean I
could get on with anyone it doesn't
bother me get somebody faster they think
this resume is because they've got
probably themselves there is a cure he
knew what he wanted to ask and it would
come straight out we were able to just
sit and have a really casual polite
conversation where he was asking
questions and he was listening to the
answers which is kind of all you need
really to be honest with y'all I think
that it's a conversation that can be
talked about amongst people amongst
different kinds of genders if you said
why have you called me there and started
to unravel the reasons why that might I
talked about more if that person had
been a train in a minute well I don't
see no why anyway someone offend me is
if they was truly trying to offend me
and then the fact but I'd know if they
was yeah it's a difference it's like
someone comes up to and says thanks to
you right it might be wrong in their
eyes and their heart they're genuinely
right
no war
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay now you can fly that good
[Music]
as soon as I got chatting especially to
mark but as soon as I started cutting to
mark things that most like tender soul
he's like really into you guys and took
cookie and he's got a fashioned it's
better interested in the next things
that's a really good conversation where
someone might be from a different
background different area of different
wherever and words could be taken in the
wrong content I don't think we
necessarily like occupy like the same
kind of clubs and spaces but if it was
like I never joined a band if Rachel's
like come out with their lives okay what
do you guys think of me what's been your
bird's directive I also used a bullet
step right put using nuts so she thought
the kill version of you